make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking up with
uh dark knight's death metal and it's
kind of crazy because this is basically
at least this first part is the story of
the dr manhattan who laughs which is
kind of nuts but
there are some things that we have to
explain here we have to make some sense
out of things those of you guys who are
reading scott snyder's justice league
once you finished it and then you picked
up with the new run if you chose to
seem to have this just massive shift
right like seemingly out of nowhere it
went from like the end of the multiverse
to like
suddenly everything's back to the way
that it used to be and the reason for
that is because of this
because of of dark knight's death metal
right so this is one of those stories
that kind of fits in between things that
are going on but even this story itself
is led into by an event called hellerism
now i didn't really cover hello isn't it
wasn't a very good story didn't really
like it too much but
the overall gist of it which you can
summarize the entire thing it was four
issues long you can summarize the entire
thing in like 30 seconds the whole
idea behind that is that you basically
have the batman who laughs and his
injustice league or whatever you want to
call it going against lex luthor and
what ended up happening here was
basically the batman who laughs ended up
approaching perpetua and what it
basically did or at least what batman
who laughs did was basically tell
perpetua hey if you
basically let me replace lex luthor then
i'll give you access to
the dark multiverse all the energy
gained with it and the reason why was
because the justice league had basically
channeled the power of dr manhattan for
lack of a better word and then used that
as kind of the antithesis
to perpetua and so they were in effect
kind of a stalemate uh with the batman
who laughs coming in and basically
allowing her to tap into the power of
the dark multiverse this boosted her
power even more and then she effectively
won
and that's where this goes in it goes in
with her basically traveling around the
multiverse conquering different worlds
things like that what this will most
likely do when it ends
is bookend into the current one of the
justice league or at least set things
back to normal so the beginning of the
justice league run makes sense right so
that's kind of how this works so he's
kind of how it fits in that's why when
you pick up with the story
everything sucks right you know
basically this realm of hell which was
formerly themyscira in the main dc
universe that's why nothing here really
matches up but you basically got wonder
woman just kind of doing your thing
right just you know with this crazy
looking doctor manhattan chainsaw and
then basically being met by uh by alec
uh alec holland right being met by swamp
thing i always want to call him alec
mason uh which is not that's not right
that's not what his name is
but basically it's it's him basically
saying like hey you know the leader's
here right like he's calling a meeting
together with everybody now for the most
part a lot of the villains or
various not even really heroes but a lot
of the villains that we're normally
familiar with the joker
the riddler captain cold from the flash
mythos that they're all basically kind
of held here
in this prison of sorts right and the
joker kind of makes a couple off-handed
remarks but there's nothing really too
spectacular here you've also got
basically this kind of magical looking
batman that almost kind of looks like
zatanna right so like that mage right
because he turns into a giant uh giant
t-rex kind of a funny moment here when
he's talking to wonder woman you know
she's kind of like okay like you're not
batman
and the response to this guy is but like
i am basically i'm a version of batman
from a different universe like all the
other ones that are here uh who have
you know he was essentially able to tap
into magic and control magic and wonder
woman's like yeah but can you throw
batarangs and it's like well i'm working
on that right like it's
it's just kind of poking fun into it a
little bit but that's where things are
at the moment basically this entire
realm is filled with all these different
batmen from across
the dark multiverse right the earth is
just flooded with those so in effect
the batman who laughs one right he
basically ended up winning here and so
with that being the case they end up
kind of bringing in
this new prisoner of sorts and this this
new prisoner for a brief second
basically just says diana
remember and it doesn't really seem to
kind of snap
like like jog back a memory or anything
it just kind of seems to be this guy
knows who he is or knows who who she is
and is trying to tell her like remember
how everything was or whatever the case
is now at this point we're not talking
about a dream sequence we're literally
talking about the conquering of the
world and so because that what we end up
doing is switching over to the batman
who laughs himself
and scott snyder kind of takes a bit of
a jab right you know kind of a little
bit of a joke here well the first thing
he he kind of opens up with is you know
i know
we're so sick of you like we're tired of
you and to a degree that's kind of true
here's the issue with the batman who
laughed the batman who last was an
amazing concept
it was an amazing idea and it was
groundbreaking at the time in the sense
of a batman who was infected by the
joker toxin which we'd kind of seen
before but being pushed to this degree
had never really been seen before the
issue is because he proved to be so
popular dc took it and ran with it and
so you saw the batman who laughs in
everything
the results of this is that unless
somebody unless scott snyder was writing
it it just couldn't really be done
justice because at the end of the day
the batman who laughs wasn't really a
character with a story being told he was
a plot device
you know in in effect and so it took
away from the meaning of his character
now scott snyder knows how to write him
you know it's scott snyder's baby and
that's why the way you see him written
here is kind of the way he's supposed to
be but nonetheless you know
it's one of these things where he
basically tells you know the the various
people who were here that perpetua's
conquered a different world you know all
these different batman that are in this
current location one of them talks about
how superman is almost
coming to the anti-life equation you've
got aquaman who's there is basically a
servant of sorts you got shazam you've
got these different guys
here but they're all basically here
against their will right the the
alternative is to die right like if they
fight
if they come out and just launch an
attack against the batman who laughs
they'll die
quite readily right at the hands of
batman who lasts himself or his forces
or perpetua because they basically lost
right it's a massive amount of power
that they're going against and for for
wonder woman she's kind of met by
by a sort of communication from batman
himself right from like the main batman
and it's one of these things where he
basically says that when jon jones set
up a psychic link he found a way to
essentially hijack the signal right so
he can basically talk into anybody's
brain
anytime he wants to and what happens you
get this kind of discussion here the
batman basically says they cannot launch
an all-out attack against the batman who
lasts it'll fail
it won't work that way wonder woman
wants to go into the pit where the
prisoner was taken
and find out what this person knows who
this person is and see if they can
basically succeed in her plan now her
plan here
and what she wants to do is launch a
full-on attack against the batman who
laughs but there's actually more to it
than that but at the end of the day the
the response of batman is we have to
make small strikes we have to take small
steps now of course this leads to her
almost kind of zoning out and really
only focusing on her conversation with
batman which of course
draws the attention of the batman who
laughs and so in response to this of
course batman makes his move we find out
he's there the entire time and kind of
keeping an eye on things by basically
using an
invisibility cloak and then as soon as
he makes his presence known the batman
who laughs
tells us guys to attack and when they go
on the affront against you know against
wonder woman you've got aquaman of
course who's attacked as well and and
wonder woman who's able to hold her own
to a degree but the crazy thing about
this
is batman is in possession of a black
lantern wing now that's that's the
craziest thing about this right because
what he does is basically start
resurrecting all these corpses right
just bringing all these dead bodies back
to life now these guys are cannon fodder
all they're designed to do is even the
odds that's really the only purpose here
the big goal behind batman is to use
them as a distraction to grab wonder
woman and to grab jonah hex and to grab
a few other people here and there and
then bail out as fast as they possibly
can
right and so the reason why that matters
is because what it does is it offers
them a chance to basically kind of go
their own separate ways wonder woman
pursues her plan batman pursues his plan
and kind of going from there but wonder
woman makes her way down into the pit
where the prisoner's being held and we
end up finding out this is basically
dr manhattan wally west now the reason
why this matters is this comes out of a
story called flash forward where wally
west had more or less gained the powers
of dr manhattan you know and then
ultimately ended up traveling the
multiverse now there was a cool story in
and of itself
and we can cover it but nonetheless it's
one of these things where he's kind of
conversing with
wonder woman and saying there doesn't
really seem to be a way to reverse this
right like we can't undo this like it
doesn't really seem to be the case where
one of them
asks like fill in the blanks tell me
what's going on here what scott snyder
does here
is in effect completely rewrite the
entirety of the dc
universe at least in insofar as a lot of
what we've seen so far and it's kind of
a cool thing
because over the course of the flash
forward story a lot of this was
introduced and what we basically learned
is that all the evil that exists in the
dc universe as it stands now can be
described
as more or less anti-crisis and i'm
sorry as crisis
energy right so there are basically
poles here there's like the north pole
in the south pole more or less but these
poles are kind of broken down into
what's called
crisis energy and connective energy
crisis energy is
all the evil energy that exists out
there all the bad guys basically emanate
from this kind of
source of energy to a degree now it's
not designed to say like superboy prime
is powered by crisis energy it's
designed to say this is kind of what
they represent this is the
the concept that they stand for and on
the other side of that you have
connective energy things like the speed
force
the emotional spectrum of the the
lantern cores out there that it all kind
of binds them and that's how these
things are tied together
that this kind of energy right selfish
you know selfishness greed you know
predation and all that kind of stuff
these are these are all things that are
sort of tied together under what is
effectively
evil and then goodness is is basically
things like love
and compassion so on and so forth and
that when all these various energies
kind of come together and smash against
each other it happens in the form of a
crisis right whatever form that crisis
may take and that for the most part
perpetua
were the role of somebody like perpetual
or at least the various versions of her
which is to say her counterparts right
people who were tasked with going into
this
endless void and creating different
multiverses where they created those
multiverses using connective energy
perpetua created the multiverse using
crisis energy and what this did is it
led to a corrupt and screwed up universe
and so
i guess a corrupt and screwed up
multiverse and so because of that this
led to the people who created her who
oversaw her actions basically locking
her away in the source wall
wiping away her her crisis-based uh
universe and then replacing it with a
connective multiverse and that's how the
current multiverse came to be
right and so the result of that is where
she had kind of reached out from the
source wall and tried to grab different
people for the purpose of bringing back
the multiverse the way that she wanted
it to be one of these was barbados and
that's the reason why barbados did what
he did
breaking out of the dark multiverse
entering into the positive multiverse
whether he was working
explicitly for perpetua or he simply
became aware of what the multi of the
positive multiverse and what it could be
if it was transformed by
him we're not really given a definitive
answer here but this is just one of the
many avatars that functioned at least as
a result of perpetua's whispers the fact
that she was trying to reach out the
battle with barbados is what
shattered the source wall and that's
what led to perpetua being free but the
whole idea
here is that every time there's been any
kind of a major crisis in dc comics it's
because
this balance of crisis energy and
connectivity energy basically led to an
imbalance meaning crisis energy became
more powerful or simply the two of them
just came into conflict with each other
it's a delicate balance that always has
to exist and that's why that's why this
is so wild
is because he goes on to explain that
with the batman who laughs that he
basically managed to talk to perpetua
and get perpetua to bend it or at least
to allow him into her ranks which
basically powered her with all this dark
multiverse energy right so as all these
different cons that have been created
and all kind of come together
in this this one particular story it's
very easy to lose track of how
overly massive this is right how huge
this is in scale and so because of that
the batman who laughs basically pops up
here right and reveals that he's been
listening to everything this entire time
and and all that kind of stuff and
almost kind of
toys with wonder woman right this idea
that she says i know everything you're
going to do because i'm bruce wayne and
the response of wonder woman is yes but
that's your weakness
right when you fight batman your
strength is you know everything he's
going to do before he even does it
because you are him but you're not me
you're the batman who lasts not the
wonder woman who laughs right i'm not
going to make some kind of a sword to
take you out i already have a weapon and
then she in turn dawns her weapon
and kills the batman who laughs just
like that batman who laughs is dead
from there the bat mage immediately
bails out and basically goes and tells
everybody the batman who laughs is dead
it's time to begin his final plan it's
time to prepare the final bruce wayne
this final bruce wayne
just by looking at him is a dr manhattan
who laughs right that's what this guy is
at some point along the line
in some either in the dark multiverse or
some alternate reality bruce wayne
somehow managed to attain the power of
dr manhattan right and that's what's so
crazy about this because from there we
kind of skipped forward a bit right we
sort of pick up with wonder woman
and with batmo beast basically like some
super advanced version
of an ai using batman's brain that turns
into like a giant
robot of sorts and right now it's just a
giant monster truck but
you know you basically have this
scenario where what wonder woman is
looking for
is a is a kind of cemetery right this
kind of hidden away cemetery that nobody
knows about not even wally west knew
about it despite
all of his wanted power this place was
it was hidden away right it's called the
valhalla cemetery it's the crypt for
various heroes who exist out there
and so when that happens of course
wonder woman and and wally west and uh
matt moby's
i think batmobile stays up top but uh
swamp thing all make their way down
there
and are immediately attacked by green
lantern constructs and so when when she
basically says stand down and then the
questions asked
what's the password she says the last
password that i knew was uncle the beast
disband they basically go away
and she's met by the arrival of the jsa
of jay garrick dr fate allen scott the
green lantern and wildcat right these
guys are old and this is very very
important the reason why
is because this looks like the jsa as
it's supposed to exist now
the main dc universe justice society of
america for those of you guys who don't
know what i'm referring to here uh
before crisis on infinite uras in 1986
1987 the jsa was an alternate reality as
most of you guys know
it existed in an alternate universe
called earth 2. the issue with this was
that crisis on infinite earth was
designed to get rid of the multiverse
and so you couldn't explain the jsa as
existing from an alternate reality if
there were no alternate realities
anymore and so dc fixed this in the
early 1990s with the return of the jsa
by basically saying they were
superheroes who existed in the in the
1940s and 1950s right world war ii
superheroes by the time the modern day
justice league of barry allen and batman
and superman and wonder woman and all
those guys had shown up the jsa had
basically retired and by whatever manner
and whatever means they ended up coming
out of retirement and going back to
being superheroes again the whole point
is it's kind of a return to these heroes
right not only that once they actually
get down into the crypt what batman is
doing and this is actually a genius move
what batman is doing is going from crypt
to crypt alongside jonah hex and
basically grabbing these various people
now the reason why he chooses jonah hex
here is because jonah hex has been
around for a long long time
and he's basically cross paths with
everyone it's one of the reasons why
so many fans of dc love the character of
jonah hex because he's unique he's
he's intriguing in his own way he's
almost a kind of punisher-esque
character but basically he's a guy who's
been around the block more than a few
times
and batman having jonah hex follow him
and then running over all these various
names right liberty bell who we haven't
seen for a long time
because she's been dead asking the
question should we resurrect her phantom
lady uncle sam
it's almost blackest night in the way
that it's being done right black is
night and brightest day and the way that
this is happening
the other big thing about this is that
batman's plan here is to basically say
like we need to
resurrect some of these guys right it's
kind of a cool thing because you see
like johnny quick
on this tomb sandman wesley dodds dove
right donald hall like like you see
these these kind of characters with the
potential to be resurrected here and the
response of batman is no our job is to
go here and to grab each one of these
guys
and to launch a series of small attacks
against the forces of the batman who
last but the problem is that you killed
him you killed the batman who last we
knew what we were fighting when he was
alive and we knew how to overcome him i
fought him enough times to know
what his weaknesses are how to get
around him different things like that
but now that he's dead
who the hell knows what we're gonna be
facing off against right you've made the
situation worse
because instead of us fighting against
the known now we're fighting against the
unknown and we're just gonna have to
wait for him to make his move before we
know what it is that we're fully going
up against but whatever it is we're
facing off against i can promise you
it's worse than what we fought before
and the response of wonder woman is that
doesn't matter i did what i needed to do
like i needed to kill him like at the
very least it gives us a fighting chance
because now his forces are in disarray
and the response to batman is
but only temporary and that's the
shortcoming of wonder woman here and
that's that's kind of the nature of her
character not in the sense it is a fault
not in the sense that she's screwed up
but in the sense that wonder woman is
not a thinker
like she's not the sharpest tool in the
shed she's got some experience under her
belt but she's a fighter that's the
whole
basis behind her character and so it's
basically wonder woman wasn't thinking
ahead here and so in the midst of all
this with wonder woman kind of
making her plan known in the sense that
her idea is to basically
gather all these energy sources together
and recreate the entirety of the
multiverse right so basically wipe
everything out and recreate everything
again
this is where we're met with the arrival
of barry allen right that literally jay
garrick calls out for barry who shows up
here
and all barry's been doing is just kind
of running trying to stay undetected
different things like that so it's
almost kind of kingdom coming that way
except in kingdom come it was wally and
not barry allen but
you know it's one of these things where
where jay garrick asks how much of the
speed force is left and barry says
there's really not a whole lot that he's
burned out what's left by trying to go
back and to fix things now that really
shows how desperate the situation is
because as we know after the events of
flashpoint barry allen does not like
time traveling anymore because the
ramifications can be unpredictable
and so ultimately that's when wonder
woman says my idea here is to go to new
apocalypse you know basically what was
the the headquarters the base of
operations for the batman who laughs
free all of our friends there and then
using all of our friends do
you know more or less what we try to do
before but this time we create the
entirety of the multiverse and then be
done with it right just recreate
everything wipe everything out and do it
all over again it's almost kind of
crisis in that way and so what we end up
doing is jumping back to castle bat
right the the
main fortress of the batman who laughs
and it's one of these things where it's
kind of scott snyder just being like
yeah it's the thing that's happening
they cut open the head of this dr
manhattan who laughs
and they take the brain of the batman
who laughs and they put it inside the
body of doctor manhattan now
under any normal circumstance this
couldn't be done right it's ridiculous
even for science fiction but what we are
talking about here is a being with the
power of dr manhattan there really isn't
anything beyond his
his capability to achieve here taking a
brain and just slapping it in there the
rest will take care of itself right
that's the nature of manhattan he wasn't
really a
he was basically an energy being right
he was being composed of pure energy he
didn't really have
a tried and true physical form anymore
and so with that being the case
once the brain slapped in there then
basically manhattan just kind of starts
to wake up
and has the mind of the batman who
laughs inside and initially he's just
kind of like sputtering words and
talking gobbly [ __ ] and nonsense and not
really making any sense and the bat mage
kind of writes him off as like okay
he's just a vegetable this is this has
failed and then in turn the batmage gets
destroyed
only for us to basically realize that
now the batman who laughs is in total
possession of the power of dr manhattan
now much like we saw with perpetua it
takes time to ramp this up right it
takes time for this energy
to start boosting up and getting back to
100 so right now he's exceedingly
powerful but he's still in somewhat of a
weakened state and so when the
question's kind of asked when he takes
on this form perpetua reaches out to him
and says hey like what's going on
i sent some kind of a disturbance the
response of him is no everything's fine
right
it's fine here on this end how are
things going out there and her whole
answer is well i'm taking out another
universe right this time it's the
superman red sun universe it looks like
and so using this power that he has
the dr manhattan who laughs basically
wipes away all the various forces who
were there
leaving only one of his crows and so the
whole indication here is that he plans
on using this power you know he's using
perpetua right he's probably going to
try to use super power or something like
that and recreate everything we don't
know what his grand scheme is but i have
a very hard time believing that from
what we've seen of his character that
he's going to be anybody's henchman he's
nobody's bane it just doesn't work that
way
he's the guy who's running the show and
if he's working for you it's because
he's using you to achieve his goal and
as soon as he doesn't need you then
he'll get rid of you and so he basically
kind of starts talking to his talking to
his crow and says like tell me your
story like tell me what it is that's
going on with you the kid whispers
something we never really find out what
it is and then he seems to kind of laugh
about it and so following that he
basically uses his power to realize that
wonder woman and her forces are making
their moves or at least
you know making their plans to work
against the batman who laughs to try to
seize control of the ability to recreate
all of reality but the batman who laughs
says
having all this power i have to now take
on my final form right it's kind of kind
of a weird thing right it's like i'm
taking on my new form my absolute real
form and he basically kind of
restructures himself into this almost
you know shadowy appearance and refers
to himself as the darkest knight but if
i'm being honest with you i'll never see
him as the darkest knight i'm going to
see him as basically the dr manhattan
who laughs but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you